revenge of the Fallen dark of the moon
age of extinction and now the last night
you may think the story lines and
direction to Michael Bay's transformers
vision shape-shift about as much as
their Autobot protagonists but they make
big bucks and so expect more films to
follow I'm Simon and this is your
Cybertronian news update the name of the
next movie in Michael Bay's transformers
film franchise has been revealed and
it's titled transformers the last night
Paramount Pictures Australia revealed
the title alongside a short teaser not
many details have been released about
the film other than its shed will to be
released in June 2017 production on the
movie will kick off in June this year
and it will be the fifth Transformers
film in the movie series which kicked
off in 2007 with transformers earlier
this year paramount announced that it
will be releasing a new Transformers
movie every year until at least 2019 the
studio confirmed the release dates for
the next three movies transformers 6 is
scheduled to debut on June 8 to 2018 and
transformers 7 will follow on June 28
2019 in January Michael Bay confirm that
although he was returning to the
director's chair for the fifth
Transformers film it will be his final
movie in the series in an interview with
Rolling Stone who said I still have a
great time it's fun to do a movie that a
hundred million people will see but this
is the last one I have to pass the range
to someone else it's time to move on
one more are you a fan of the
Transformers films or are you bored of
all the bay Hemme let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter I'm
at the jaqen or thanks for watching and
for all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot